they are the two computer whiz kids who
Change the World As We Know It Larry and
Surya always had this kind of
irreverence as part of their attitude
which is what made them so creative
these two Founders really think of
themselves as nobleman they think that
what they're doing is good for the world
[Music]
Larry Page and Sergey Brin were the kind
of guys who kept Bill Gates up at night
journalist canaletta I said Mr Gates
what is your nightmare and I thought he
would say apple or Netscape or Oracle
look and he said I'll tell you what I
worry about I worry about some guy in a
garage inventing a new technology
Microsoft has never thought about
well the 98 two guys were in a garage
and the hand-letted sign and it said
Google worldwide headquarters
in an industry where Innovation is just
part of the job description Larry Page
and Sergey Brin have become virtual
Masters of the Universe of information
gathering
what we don't know we Google 629
000 results wow and all this time I
thought Googling yourself meant the
other thing not anymore
Silicon Valley is littered with startups
that have stalled out
why are these two computer science Geeks
succeeded may have a lot to do with the
nearly parallel lives they LED before
creating together one of the world's
largest and most powerful companies
Brennan page respectfully declined to
participate in this program
Sergey Brin was born in the Soviet Union
in 1973. his parents were mathematicians
and Jewish which limited their career
opportunities
Mark Mao seed is the co-author of the
Google story so sergey's father went to
a conference in Warsaw met a whole bunch
of colleagues from the West saw what
life was like outside the Soviet Union
came back sat the family down and said
we have to leave
his parents brought with them a sense of
purpose they instilled in their son it
boiled down to a simple message don't
come back with a B don't come back with
the second place award make it first
always and Sergey internalized this and
it did form a core part of his
personality
like Brynn Larry Page was born in 1973
his family lived in Michigan and his
father was the first person in his
family to get a college degree
both of his parents were in similar
Fields as brynn's they were the second
generation computer science which at
that time was very unusual because
computer science was really only
developing as a field in the 60s and
here both of their parents were Advanced
degrees they see themselves as on a
mission and that mission
it really does spring from their
biographies in 2009 Paige shared that
mission with the graduating class at the
University of Michigan you know what
it's like to wake up in the middle of
the nights with a vivid dream
and you know how if you don't have a
pencil and pad by the bed it will be
completely gone by the next morning I
had one of those dreams when I was 23.
when I suddenly woke up I was thinking
what if we could download the whole web
and just keep the links and I grabbed a
pen and started writing
soon after I told my advisor Terry
Winograd it would take a couple of weeks
for me to download the web he nodded
knowingly fully aware it would take much
longer but wise enough not to tell me
Stanford professor and Engineering
consultant to Google Terry Winograd
Larry just thinks of ways of doing
things that you might not expect Sergey
was a lot like Larry he also was someone
who really wanted to think outside the
box to say if that sounds like it's
impossible let's try it it was 1995 at
Stanford University when the headstrong
overachievers first met
one of their Stanford professors used to
say well the difference between the two
of them was that Sergey would just burst
into my office without asking Larry
would knock and then versed in
[Music]
in the 90s searching the internet was
rudimentary Hit or Miss often returning
results that were useless and the
process was very slow then you typed in
your query you did something else while
you waited for it to get the results
then you went back and looked at the
results and most of them were completely
irrelevant Paige and Brynn pushed for
something better
sergey's big interest was in taking all
the pages on the world wide web and
trying to make sense of it trying to
find patterns they started to do a
record of backlinks they called them
thank you
Paige noticed that behind every web page
there were hundreds or even thousands of
other pages that linked to it
[Music]
was a Eureka moment that would change
the so-called Information Age
then they realized that that list of
backlinks could be used for ranking
more backlinks it showed you were a
better page
if a lot of other websites linked to a
web page that probably meant users
thought it was good
genius was recognizing that this kind of
algorithm could give you the kind of
results that mattered the most to
Searchers Paige and Brynn had their
secret formula now it needed a name the
guys were looking for a great name that
was going to capture the grandiose
Vision that they had and hit upon this
giant number
one with 100 zeros after it commonly
known as Google
g-o-o-g-o-l they discovered it was owned
they said you know what let's put a
friendlier spelling on it
on September 15 1997 they registered
Google as a website
and Paige and Brynn dropped out of their
PHD programs to focus on attracting
funding for their young company it
wouldn't be easy investors like Ram
charam were skeptical there were five
search engines at the time and so I said
maybe any one of them might be
interested in the Technologies and the
world didn't need a sixth search engine
Google just didn't fit into the
conventional wisdom of what a website
should do which was to keep users from
migrating to another page
Google did the unthinkable it helped
users explore the wider web
Larry Page and Sergey Brin had a
different attitude they said we don't
want a portal we want to get the search
results to them in a Split Second
so one Sunday morning Larry and Sergey
were sitting on the porch of a Stanford
Professor a friend of theirs and Andy
becklesheim one of the founders of sun
Microsystems pulls up in his sports car
walks up gets about a 10 minute demo
says this is fantastic this is the next
big big thing and writes a check on the
spot for a hundred thousand dollars made
out to Google Inc Stephen Levy is senior
writer of Wired Magazine this is the way
things work in Silicon Valley you know
it it sounds astounding that someone
would just write a hundred thousand
dollar check and get you going but you
have to realize that there was a hidden
pedigree to this they were at Stanford
their professors had done this before
this is a pretty good bet we might lose
a hundred thousand dollars but we could
win big there and at the time we had no
company at all and in fact we couldn't
cash the check
this by the way with no legal documents
and they know none of that stuff
and even though they had the seed money
they still needed much more cash no one
was buying into Google
they went back to ram charam
they found three other investors and
together we raised enough money to get
them off the ground
enough money was one million dollars
including two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars from Jeff Bezos of amazon.com
Paige and Brynn Incorporated Google on
September 4th 1998 and they moved into
one of those storied garages in Menlo
Park
they attracted the attention of two
well-known Silicon Valley venture
capitalists Michael Moritz of Sequoia
capital and John Dorr of Kleiner Perkins
both wanted an exclusive deal
Brennan page said No Deal that the
presence of mine at their tenderizer in
their mid-20s then to say we won't take
money from only one venture capitalist
we want to assure that neither one of
them has controls we're going to split
it in June of 1999 Google issued its
first press release announcing the
investment 25 million dollars
Brennan page now needed to hire
first-rate Engineers people who would
meet their exacting standards Chris Saka
is a former googler it was one of the
most intense hiring processes of any
company in the world I had somewhere
between 12 and 15 interviews over just a
couple days they created a headquarters
they called the Googleplex offering
employee services like free food and
child care and developed the informal
Company motto of don't be evil
but Google still wasn't making money
Larry would come in and I would say well
how are you going to make money from
this
Google co-founders Larry Page and Sergey
Brin had created a new search engine but
had yet to find a way to turn it into
profit they didn't like the idea of
using advertising to cash in
at first they thought advertising was
grubby commercial kind of unseemly
they are famously sparse homepage was
originally designed by Sergey Brin
unlike Rivals Yahoo and AOL Paige and
Brynn refused to clutter their home page
with ads
we won't take any ads on the homepage
because we think to build use of trust
we want to not feel like we're bogging
them down with advertisements yet no ads
at all meant no Revenue
Paige and Brynn had to accept
advertising as their only option there
were search engines in the early days
which when you went to a page the first
few things which looked just like
regular search results happened to be
things that the sponsors of those had
paid the search engine to put there and
they said that's not good for users I
don't want the things that somebody else
wants me to see I want the things that I
want to see
then they found a compromise they could
live with
they invented a new way of targeting
text ads triggered by search requests
instead of distracting pop-ups or
flashing ads these small ads were placed
above and next to search results it's
familiar now but revolutionary back then
they called it Google AdWords businesses
big and small could take control of
their advertising dollars by purchasing
ads key to certain words
David Thacker was a project manager on
AdWords advertisers love the system
because they only pay when someone
actually clicks on their ad for many
advertisers it's the most efficient form
of marketing they ever have
for businesses it was the Holy Grail a
direct connection to their best
customers with a massive new Revenue
Source Google exploded
by September of 2000 it had indexed a
billion URLs and was available in 15
languages
still with all of Google success few
people outside Silicon Valley knew who
had created it
Sergey Brin went on to tell the truth
and fooled the judges will a real Sergey
Brin please stand up
[Applause]
but media Moguls knew exactly who they
were Barry Diller was one of the first
traditional media Executives to physical
guys Larry is sitting there with his PDA
his little handheld device and he's
looking down and doing his email and he
says Larry please I'm talking to you can
we just Converse and he says I can do
both Roberto says no you can't do both
choose he says I choose this
with tremendous growth came other
challenging issues for the search giant
Google The Venture capitalists behind
the company Michael Moritz and John Dorr
were pressuring its co-founders to hire
a CEO they were resistant but they
didn't want to say you know we can do it
but they thought they could do it they
went through 12 13 14 interviews they
didn't like any of the people they they
saw they visited Steve Jobs just to meet
him because he was a hero of theirs and
they said to John Deere after the
meeting why can't he be our CEO John
door introduced Paige and Brynn to Eric
Schmidt a businessman with an
engineering background
you just hired Eric Schmidt he's come
over to run Google
yes basically what's the idea behind
that
um you guys couldn't run it yourself
parental supervision to be honest you
know Eric is a grown-up in in the room I
mean he's he's in his mid 50s not
mid-30s he's got a lot of experience
he's more of a diplomat than they are
and that's needed in dealing with the
traditional media World which they
increasingly are bumping up against
by the end of 2001 Eric Schmidt was
Google CEO
Paige became president of products and
Brynn the president of Technology the
two Founders still shared an office they
have a mind Mill they anticipate each
other's words they back each other up
there's no sense of tension between them
that's one of the great strengths of
that company with Eric Schmidt in place
Google kept up its spectacular growth
while its Rivals slowly faded away
the search engine linked to 3 billion
web pages and forged a partnership with
AOL which brought them 34 million new
customers you had this incredibly
profitable company how are you going to
get it to the next level how are you
going to provide the kind of Capital
Growth that they needed
the solution it was time for Google to
go public being unconventional they
decided that they were going to hold an
IPO unlike any That Wall Street had ever
seen they were going to set the price
via an auction to determine and try to
extract the greatest value from the
stock
the stock price on August 19 2004 closed
at just over 100 a share making the
company worth more than 23 billion
dollars
the two Founders became billionaires
soon the company expanded with Google
Maps Google news and Google Earth
their idealism and bold ideas had built
their reputation but the company was
stumbling with their free email service
email was a great product that was
really poorly launched when users saw
ads pop up that were directly related to
their personal emails alarms went off
when people first saw these ads they
were shocked because they thought how
could these ads be so targeted you know
I'm reading this this email about uh you
know my friend's vacation to Hawaii I'm
getting ads about Hawaii is somebody
snooping into my email
the concern around Gmail launched a much
deeper fundamental argument about
privacy and Trust do you know how
Google's using all the information it
collects on you all of the web searches
that I've done for years and years all
of the emails that I've done potentially
information about health records
information about the books that I'm
looking at information about where I'm
going because I'm typing it into Google
Maps
in a sense they're the big brother that
we've been talking about all these years
the ultimate big brother was about to
put their don't be evil philosophy to
the test
in 2006 Google reached an agreement with
China for access to their 400 million
web users with one condition they censor
search results of banned topics
for Brynn son of Russian immigrants it
was a troubling decision
at Google's Friday meeting Sergey spoke
with passion about growing up in the
Soviet Union and how his parents
literally escaped the Soviet Union to
come to America what that meant to him
and that dialogue happened including
everybody they wanted to hear from all
the employees there Sergey swallowed
hard but they all said at Google this is
the biggest consumer Market in the world
we have to be here
Google agreed to Chinese demands I know
there was a lot of controversy
surrounding that and we had to
self-censor a fair amount but we were
actually able to censor less and less
and our local competitors there are also
sensor less and less so I feel like our
entry
made a big difference
um
but things started going downhill
Google discovered a Cyber attack on
their systems
the more troubling thing to me is that
we discovered the motivation which we
believed to be to gain access to Gmail
accounts in particular for Chinese human
rights activists Google pulled the plug
and redirected users to an unfiltered
site in Hong Kong that isn't subject to
censorship Leave Britney Spears alone
right now YouTube began as a place for
people to share Home Videos it soon grew
into one of the world's top search
engines by July 2006 users were
uploading 65 000 videos a day and Google
wanted in
they went out and acquired YouTube for
1.65 billion dollars in Google stock
YouTube Founders Chad Hurley and Steve
Chen were thrilled today we have some
exciting news for you we've been
acquired by Google yeah thanks
in 2006 Google CEO Eric Schmidt
acknowledged that to stay competitive
the company also had to enter the world
of mobile phones in fact a year earlier
they had quietly bought another startup
Android a small company with software
for cell phones there's so many more
mobile phones than personal computers as
people do more and more searches on
mobile phones it should eventually
balance out again this would be many
years it didn't take years Apple's
phenomenal success with the iPhone in
2007 set a collision course between the
two companies very exciting to be here
today months later Brennan page
announced their Android operating system
would run on a variety of mobile phones
their longtime Idol Steve Jobs slammed
Google for entering the phone business
and accused them of trying to kill the
iPhone
at the Google developer conference in
May of 2010 Google's vice president of
engineering tore into Apple
if Google did not act we faced a
Draconian future a future where one man
one company one device one carrier would
be our only choice
that's a future we don't want
and Google is battling with another
Giant in the tech World they bump up
against Microsoft in so many ways they
have a browser Chrome Microsoft has
Internet Explorer Google also acquired
companies that dealt with online
versions of word processing software and
spreadsheets things that directly go
after Microsoft's jugular with their
office product
Microsoft fired back with its own search
engine Bing which debuted in Spring of
2009. can I ask what you make of Bing do
you like it
um I think uh you a bing user uh oh yeah
no no I I use I use all search engines
out there uh I think that what Bing has
reminded us uh uh is that the search is
a very competitive market
Bing ironically offered Google
protection by letting them Dodge
accusations of being a monopoly
Bill Gates said this is the company that
is closest to us as a competitor they
are just as hungry and as ruthless he
didn't use that word but I am as we are
there is a danger they make a lot of
enemies it's a blind spot because these
two Founders really think of themselves
as noblemen they think that what they're
doing is good for the world they've
always enjoyed feeling like the underdog
feeling like the evil empire was
Microsoft and now they've discovered
that and some people think they're the
evil empire
their own slogan do no evil was suddenly
being used against them
Google's Quest on the road to organize
the world's information took a new turn
call it a detour with an ambitious
feature they called street view an
attempt to photograph every neighborhood
on the planet
it would eventually include ordinary
images from Main Street to extraordinary
views of Antarctica
but the effort also took private user
information from unsecured Wi-Fi
locations many people felt their privacy
had been compromised
Google acknowledged the mistake and
agreed to destroy data
the company known for search was
struggling to diversify and was facing
an aggressive new Challenger Mark
Zuckerberg
Facebook's 1 billion users spend more
time on the social network posting
valuable information that is invisible
to Google's search engine information
that all advertisers Chase
so far Google's efforts at social
networking have failed but its Founders
are keenly aware that as users habits on
the web change Google will have to make
a lot more friends
in January 2011 in a startling Silicon
Valley shake-up Eric Schmidt announced
that Google was simplifying its
management structure and that Larry Page
was ready to lead and would take over
from him as CEO co-founder Sergey Brin
will focus on new products Schmidt
tweeted day-to-day adult supervision no
longer needed
in 14 years Google grew from startup to
technology giant hitting 50 billion
dollars in Revenue in 2012.
and the space of a year Larry Page and
Sergey Brin both got married
Paige married Stanford bioinformatics
PhD Lucinda Southworth in December 2007
on Richard Branson's Island Branson was
also his best man
Brynn married biotech specialist Anne
wojitski in the Bahamas with his partner
Larry Page standing up for him they both
have two children
[Music]
google.org its philanthropic arm has
contributed over 100 million dollars to
various organizations from clean energy
to Global health
Larry Page and Sergey Brin have changed
the way we get information it's been a a
great experience for me to see them grow
over the last 12 years that I've known
them I feel extremely proud of what
they've accomplished
Larry and Surya always had this kind of
irreverence as part of their attitude
which is what made them so creative it's
great
I think Google attracts people who care
who care about users who care about
their fellow human who care about the
planet and just can't sit still they
built a company that absolutely changed
the world
[Music]
foreign
Mark Zuckerberg was a Harvard freshman
with a gift for computer programming
less than a decade later he is the
baby-faced multi-billionaire power
broker who rubbed shoulders with the
president my name is Barack Obama and
I'm the guy who got marked to wear a
jacket and tie I think most people still
haven't really digested the scale of
Facebook or how quickly it's grown the
goal is obviously to get to ubiquity I
mean Mark Zuckerberg wants everyone to
be on this service he transformed the
dorm room project into the internet's
biggest Global Village the site now has
over 900 million users it can't
underestimate how driven Mark Zuckerberg
really is Zuckerberg is just as
Visionary as Steve Jobs
he's going to prove just as influential
as Bill Gates
but for all that success Zuckerberg has
confronted bitter battles and lawsuits
over Facebook's Origins one he wanted to
control his own thing and two if he's
gonna go against someone he's gonna
crush them we spent three months working
with Mark being essentially LED on we
were all blindsided we had no idea that
he was working on a competing product he
has waged an all-out war on his biggest
competitors Facebook and Google's
relationship is pretty simple they just
don't like each other and Zuckerberg has
come under Fire for pushing the limits
on user privacy users to have less
control over private information they
don't fully know how their information
is being shared he's not dealing with
just a piece of technology he's dealing
with people
and their behavior and in many ways is
doing it on the Fly they have amassed
this humongous database of information
about us because we trusted them
so the question is should we still trust
them
[Music]
I think that the goal that we went into
it with wasn't to make an online
community but sort of like a mirror for
the real community that existed in real
life
Mark Zuckerberg we think we know him
because we've seen his life unfold in
the oscar-winning movie The Social
Network the portrait was unsparing a
Super Geek intense Cut Throat brilliant
and socially crippled I don't understand
which part but was it accurate he's
always had friends you know he's a
pretty social guy
um I think the last time I checked
879 friends on Facebook
this is the real Mark Zuckerberg in
rarely seen footage shot at Facebook's
first corporate headquarters by Young
filmmakers in 2005. one what are we
celebrating she's got three million
users three million users yeah and how
long has Facebook been around uh not
that long
a little more than a year
while Zuckerberg pushes the envelope on
user privacy he opted out of
participating in this program
in 2004 at the age of 19 he created
Facebook today the 28 year old CEO has
accumulated a net worth estimated at
15.5 billion dollars Mark's Mission from
the beginning was about connecting
people and it was clearly based on this
theory that if the world were more
connected it would be a better place but
there's a lot of surprises when you
really dig deep into the story of
Facebook the biggest single surprise is
the peculiar and tenacious personality
of Mark Zuckerberg and the you know the
depth of his convictions and his
consistency
[Music]
born in 1984 he grew up in the Hudson
River Town of Dobbs Ferry a bedroom
community North of New York City
David Kirkpatrick spent two years
researching a book about Zuckerberg and
Facebook called the Facebook effect he
comes from an unbelievably supportive
family in which he's the only son and he
has three sisters so he was kind of The
Prince and in fact I think his parents
called him the prince and he was treated
accordingly so this is a guy without any
problem of self-confidence computer
savvy from the start Zuckerberg taught
himself the complicated computer
language C plus plus and by ninth grade
had created a digital version of the
board game Risk journalist Jose Antonio
Vargas interviewed Zuckerberg for his
New Yorker magazine profile he actually
created a thing called zucknet
which is an internal instant messaging
system for the family so the computers
could talk to each other
I mean that's kind of the kid he was
[Music]
he got sort of tired of his local high
school he decided to go to Exeter Prep
School really because he just wanted
more challenge it was at the exclusive
Exeter Academy that Zuckerberg and his
friend Adam D'Angelo created a music
website called synapse it was intended
to anticipate what your preferences
might be and it was very very popular
even before he started Facebook he was
fending off offers from Microsoft and
others to buy synapse for well over a
million dollars
like a tech World version of an All-Star
athlete big name companies wanted to
recruit him right out of Exeter again
Zuckerberg was unimpressed and chose
instead to enter Harvard in 2002.
where it wasn't long before he got
himself in trouble
Zuckerberg hacked into the school's
computers to collect images of students
Nicholas Carlson is Deputy editor at
businessinsider.com you can sort of tell
that he's a little bit of a troublemaker
he creates something called face smash
his first year in Harvard and it's a
sort of hot or not for the Harvard
community and then to maintain an entire
list of Harvard students and which ones
were the most attractive ranking them by
hotness
Ellen mcgirt interviewed Zuckerberg for
Fast Company magazine face match work
and kind of a a little bit of an icky
way it made people upset obviously
people felt mocked or exposed and it was
one of the first big experiences that
Mark had with the privacy issues of the
masses
Under Pressure Zuckerberg shut down the
site the Harvard Administration board
charged him with breaching security
violating copyrights and violating
individual privacy
but by then face smash was a campus
sensation Zuckerberg had seen his future
at the same time getting trouble for the
building this mischievous web tool he
built a mischievous web tool that was
really popular I imagine that he had a
couple of sleepless nights worrying
about how how bad this thing was going
to be and was relieved when it all blew
over but was also incredibly curious
about what he could then make next
if you're a genius with genius friend
sitting in a dorm room suddenly the
world looks like a big happy open place
if you can just get into that database
at the time the technology landscape was
changing dramatically Brad Stone is a
senior writer at Bloomberg businessweek
the internet was was really a much
different world back in 2004. Professor
really demonstrates that a social
network needs to have technical chops
the site goes down all the time it's
unreliable Myspace also it's full of ads
it's very distracting it also begins to
have technical instability at Harvard
Zuckerberg met classmate and future
business partner Eduardo Saverin
author Ben mesrick is one of the few to
have interviewed savarin about the early
days of Facebook Eduardo met Mark
Zuckerberg in an underground Jewish
fraternity the underground scene at
Harvard you know these were not really
fun events these were kind of strange
little social settings really bad
parties mostly all guys and so Eduardo
and Mark met in this scene and they
became friends pretty quickly because
they were both kind of Outsiders
facemash got Zuckerberg noticed by three
insiders upperclassmen building a social
networking site called Harvard
connection Olympic rowers and twins
Cameron and Tyler Winklevoss with
partner Divya Narendra
the Harvard connection was an idea that
I'd come up with when I was a junior in
college which is at the end of 2002. the
team had been building the site for
nearly a year two of their original
programmers had moved on and they
desperately needed a new partner the
three of us are not computer programmers
by by trade or practice we did need it
in actual programmer to to write the
actual hard lines of code and we thought
Mark was that guy the trio reached out
to Zuckerberg
he was enthused excited and clearly his
his eyes were lighting up
what happened next sparked a furious
battle over how Facebook was actually
created
the details unfold in email exchanges
between Zuckerberg and the Harvard
connection team
at first Zuckerberg appeared eager
I read over all the stuff he sent and it
seems like it shouldn't take too long to
implement so we can talk about that
after I get all the basic functionality
of tomorrow night
then Zuckerberg began to delay the
project
December 4th sorry I was unreachable
tonight I just got about three of your
missed calls I was working on a problem
set
December 10th the week has been pretty
busy thus far so I haven't gotten the
chance to do much work on the site or
even think about it really
Zuckerberg was stalling because he was
busy working on a similar social
networking site based on Harvard student
directory called the Facebook
he and Saverin partnered to fund it Mark
came to him and said you know you put up
a thousand dollars and we'll launch this
site and you know there were no
contracts these were just two kids in a
dorm room really but that's where it
started
writer Nicholas Carlson interviewed more
than a dozen people involved in the
founding of Facebook and found instant
messages retrieved from Zuckerberg's
computer he said Zuckerberg sent to
Saverin according to Business Insider
the IM suggests Zuckerberg was
deliberately misleading the Winklevoss
twins he says things like look at this
site that I'm working on Harvard
connection haha they made a mistake they
asked me to do it for them because I'm
working on my own Facebook we were
always under the impression that Mark
was working on harvardconnection.com
there was never an indication from him
that he could not do the work didn't
want to do the work or was working on
something identical on the side called
the Facebook when he met with the
Winklevoss brothers the last time he saw
that he probably should tell them that
he's been working on a competing product
he sort of conferred about it with
friends but in the end he said you know
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna blank them
I'm gonna blank them in the ear
on February 4th 2004 just as he was
expected to complete work on their site
Zuckerberg and his friends instead
launched the Facebook the Winklevoss
brothers and Narendra found out about it
the same way nearly everyone else at
Harvard did it completely blindsided us
we
definitely did not expect that Mark
wanted to have control over his own
project he saw that they were on to
something cool the Winklevoss brothers
but he saw that he could do something
cooler and so one he wanted to control
his own thing and two if he's gonna go
against somebody he's gonna crush them
and that's what he did Mark Zuckerberg's
new harvard-based social networking site
the Facebook was mired in controversy
from the start just days after he
launched it in February of 2004 the
Winklevoss Twins and Divya Narendra sent
him a letter to cease and desist
in a nutshell our complaint against Mark
Zuckerberg is fraud on Justin Richmond
and breach of contract Zuckerberg
responded with a letter denying any
wrongdoing claiming his site was a
separate Venture and used none of the
same code the Winklevoss Twins and
Narendra would later appeal a 65 million
settlement with Facebook they lost in
federal court but that settlement could
now be worth 200 million dollars but
none of the vicious legal wrangling
slowed the incredible momentum of the
Facebook
at that point my roommates were kind of
like you know this is pretty cool like I
bet this would work at other schools so
we launched it at Columbia Yale and
Stanford and within a couple of weeks
each of those three schools also like
had thousands of users who were like all
right this is pretty sweet like let's
just go all out and see how many schools
we can launch the status quoip as
possible about this point in time they
started to take meetings with Venture
capitalists and with bigger advertisers
and this is all kind of Eduardo's doing
they got a pretty early deal with uh
visa and they had a deal with American
Express
um they had a number of advertisers that
came and went
um then record companies started getting
interested and they began to get some
pretty good revenue from the music
industry
enter Sean Parker who had his own
connection to the music business on a
trip to New York Zuckerberg and his
partner Eduardo Saverin had dinner with
the 24 year old co-founder of Napster
the seasoned entrepreneur and a truly
creative individual an extraordinarily
interesting person who had worked his
way into a network in the valley that is
just to die for particularly at that
point
for Zuckerberg Parker was a hero and a
role model partner savarin didn't agree
Eduardo did not think highly of Sean
from the very beginning he thought that
Sean was a snake oil salesman that they
didn't need Sean that Sean talked to big
game but was living out of a duffel bag
and had been kicked out of two companies
in the summer of 2004 with Sovereign
remaining on the East Coast Zuckerberg
left Harvard
we came out to Palo Alto for the summer
just to hang out because Palo Alto is
kind of this mythical place where you
know all the startups come from and
government launch and another 150
schools when the year started one of the
things that Mark did that was very smart
by going to Palo Alto was to actually
enter the petri dish of
entrepreneurialism particularly for new
technologies Zuckerberg and his friends
moved into a large frame house with a
swimming pool and he reconnected with
Sean Parker who later became
Zuckerberg's roommate he was the adult
supervision he's the guy who showed them
how things are done in Silicon Valley
he's the one who showed them how to meet
investors how to negotiate with them who
to hire Marcus told me stories of just
all of the guys coding late at night
around dining room tables and eating
chicken McNuggets and cereal and uh
there's partying going on Sean Parker is
bringing them around to the different
kind of cool Silicon Valley hot spots
and meanwhile the website is is growing
astronomically fast I mean there's a
million member Party by December of that
year
during this time Parker gave Zuckerberg
some shrewd advice he took to heart he
sort of looked at him and said you need
to be the founder of this thing and you
need to be the CEO forever you know you
can't turn this over to investors and
Mark is able to negotiate a series of
increasingly important investment deals
that do two things one allow him enough
operating cash to hire some of the
smartest engineers in the business and
two help them retain majority control in
the company
but tensions began to grow with
Zuckerberg's original partner Eduardo
Saverin who remained on the East Coast
Eduardo felt that you know he was the
business head of the company and he was
no longer being treated that way uh you
know Mark and Sean were taking meetings
all over California they were meeting
with Venture capitalists um and they
were kind of ignoring Eduardo he
retaliated Eduardo froze the bank
accounts to try and get Mark's attention
and Mark and Sean began to sort of
figure out a way uh to build the company
without Eduardo Zuckerberg responded and
froze Sovereign out Eduardo was removed
from the company Masthead and he
essentially became a non-entity he
became a non-person he was thrown out
and he became very upset Facebook had a
million active users on college campuses
Nationwide and big money was starting to
pour in Sean Parker the new president of
Facebook introduced Zuckerberg to
Silicon Valley angel investor Peter
Thiel who put five hundred thousand
dollars into the company then in the
spring of 2005 The Venture Capital firm
Excel Partners offered Zuckerberg 12.7
million dollars for an 11 stake in the
company and didn't ask for much control
at all walking away from that investment
Mark controlled three out of five board
seats which is a bizarre and
unprecedented situation to have one
individual
have absolute effectively dictatorial
control over the disposition and
direction of an increasingly giant
company overnight the Excel investment
gave Facebook a valuation of 100 million
dollars as Facebook's public profile
grew so did Zuckerberg's control this
time Sean Parker was edged out in August
of 2005 Parker was arrested for
suspicion of cocaine possession although
not formally charged with a crime and
immediately released it led to his
abrupt resignation as president of
Facebook he was the primary outside face
of the company and it was felt that
somebody who was under any kind of a
cloud with drugs was not the right guy
to be the public face of Facebook so
Mark reluctantly agreed that he ought to
leave Facebook was growing with
remarkable speed and Zuckerberg moved
the company from its frat light house
with the pool to a larger and more
conventional space in Downtown Palo Alto
before but the college atmosphere
remained the same one of the things that
I do focus on at Facebook is making sure
that the culture is very friendly you
know and that people hang out in terms
of managing this whole process nothing
you know nothing like I I have no idea
what I'm doing you know even their
employee interviews were different
Chris Kelly was brought on in the new
position of Chief privacy officer to
deal with Facebook's increasingly
contentious privacy issues at a time
when the entire company numbered only a
couple dozen employees the first time I
met Mark we we climbed out on the roof
out through the uh the window and did
our interview on the roof of of what was
then a world wraps and it was clear he
was young but he had a very
sophisticated understanding of what had
happened so far and where he wanted to
take the company
determined to keep Facebook's unusual
creative culture alive all night
hackathons were one way to do it we have
these hackathons at the company right
where basically everyone gets together
um and just hacks on something and
builds something all night long and the
only the only rule is that you aren't
allowed to work on at a hackathon what
you work on the rest of the time so
people work on crazy stuff
the hackathons were some of the most
kind of creative Focus that you could
ever imagine in a company imagining
these incredibly talented Engineers
coming together for a night and saying
we're going to stay up all night and
we're just going to program and we're
gonna we're gonna pick a project and
we're gonna get it done that night it's
like great make it we'll prototype it
and there'll be a prototype war and see
who wins it can be a contentious
environment
I disagree
we had an argument from Mark's point of
view this is where good ideas come from
quickly and efficiently
good ideas were flowing Zuckerberg then
made a change that would give Facebook a
sudden and dramatic boost allowing
people to identify or tag themselves and
their friends in photographs that was
huge huge change that led to massive new
use of Facebook and photos became very
rapidly by far the most used part of
Facebook and became the single biggest
driver of its growth that growth
continued in One Direction up according
to Facebook's internal tracking its user
base had shot to 5.5 million users in
less than two years and media Giants
were banging on the door in 2006 Yahoo
baited the 22 year old Zuckerberg with
an extraordinary offer a buyout for one
billion dollars
even more extraordinary Zuckerberg
turned them down
if you are a parent of someone about
Mark's age you're looking at the Yahoo
decision and thinking why did you not
take that money
it's never been about money if it was it
would have just sold out we just felt
that doing that and going down that path
would not help us build Facebook out to
what we thought it could be in 2006 Mark
Zuckerberg rejected a one billion dollar
pitch from Yahoo when MTV pushed the
ante even higher Michael J wolf was CEO
of MTV networks Mark had taken me on a
walk around Palo Alto and showed me his
apartment
and afterwards we sat down for lunch and
I told him we'd be willing to pay as
much as a billion and a half dollars to
buy Facebook outright his answer was
I think it's worth a lot more and
besides you've seen my apartment I don't
really need that pun of money and at the
same time I may never have an idea as
good as this one so I'm not that
interested in selling there was internal
strife around it no question there were
a lot of people who wanted to sell
ultimately you know Mark decided to turn
down the offers
Zuckerberg wasn't ready to sell because
he had some ideas that he thought would
make Facebook even more popular one of
them was called news feed a kind of
real-time wire service of updates about
what users were up to news feed is what
everybody is doing at that point or what
they're posting what they're linking to
the world that they live in which is
really what a newspaper is right it's a
living breathing newspaper of people
around you but many Facebook users
thought that newspaper sent out too much
information and violated their privacy
000 of them launched an online protest
to say that it was unpopular at first is
a dramatic understatement they were
under siege at the office they couldn't
leave they were surrounded by news
trucks almost 10 percent of our user
base at the time
joined the students against Facebook
news feed group
Zuckerberg was forced to apologize
I wrote his apology note himself it was
probably a good learning experience when
Facebook changed some of the Privacy
controls that was an overstep I do think
he takes those seriously
but I do think that he's willing to
continue to overstep
for the for the purpose of making a
product that he wants to make the
apology was not a surrender Zuckerberg
was sure that users would get used to
this new level of sharing and he turned
out to be right after tweaking news feed
it became one of the most popular
elements of the Facebook experience
it just happened that the first time I
ever met Mark was two days after that
happened
and I can tell you even though his
members were in open Revolt he was not
the slightest bit flustered he had
complete confidence that everything was
going to work out all right
Zuckerberg decided it was time to take
Facebook Beyond its College roots and
introduce it to the General Public
the response was stunning membership
doubled shooting up to 12 million by
2006.
Zuckerberg radically altered the
Facebook experience again when for the
first time the 23 year old CEO invited
programmers from around the world to
develop apps for Facebook it was another
Turning Point expanding Facebook from an
insular world of information to a
platform and it was like the gold rush
now you open up this wonderful platform
and in comes every kind of developer
with every kind of idea from video
sharing to games to things that blink to
things that turned into you know
ballerinos and hippos and just every
kind of fun wonderful thing
platform companies or the operating
system companies always do the best I
mean think of Microsoft you know it had
this ubiquitous Windows platform and all
these other companies wrote programs for
Windows you know Facebook's really
trying to create itself in that model
and in 2007 Microsoft itself entered the
picture this time with a deal Zuckerberg
couldn't turn down and for the first
time the world got a glimpse of what
Facebook May really be worth by the time
people are finally giving us the idea
that anyone would pay a billion dollars
for Facebook Microsoft comes along and
pays 250 million dollars for 1.6 of the
company it was outrageous it valued the
company at 15 billion dollars this took
Facebook from a thing that a lot of
people use to a thing that everyone was
talking about the 15 billion dollar
company but for a 15 billion dollar
company Facebook was only making a
meager 30 million dollars in profits to
remedy that Zuckerberg announced a
sweeping new advertising system in the
fall of 2007. one part of it let
companies set up their own Facebook
pages and advertise using social ads Lou
Kerner covers social media and owns
shares in Facebook
social ads on Facebook are ads where
they would say that your friends Meg and
Ryan like Virgin America and it turns
out not surprisingly that when you see
that your friends like a product you're
more likely to click on that ad so
social ads have been very successful on
Facebook virtually from the beginning
but another part of Facebook's new
advertising plan Beacon gave users far
more than they wanted and they let
Zuckerberg know about it
Zuckerberg's made a lot of mistakes the
next mistake which was a really big one
was Beacon you go to a third party
e-commerce site and you buy something
and unless you tell it not to really
quickly it's going to go back and tell
all your friends that you just bought a
diamond engagement ring and obviously
you know that sort of secret feeling can
cause a lot of trouble there was the the
great rallying cry that Facebook ruined
Christmas because suddenly everyone's
purchases were being broadcast to their
entire network Zuckerberg really tried
to defend it for a while it took him a
while to realize how wrong it was
on December 5th 2007 Zuckerberg made
another apology he had overreached yet
again but as with previous mistakes it
wouldn't really matter Facebook was just
too popular and it wasn't long before
Zuckerberg was loosening up the
Network's privacy controls one more time
more than four years after co-founding
Facebook Zuckerberg still seemed uneasy
in the public Spotlight what's your next
thing you're gonna do get bought
yeah
none of these rumors are true right
um you know this is
all right by 2009 rumors were indeed
swirling that Facebook would go public
instead Zuckerberg took money from a new
investor Yuri Milner CEO of the Russian
internet investment firm digital Sky
Technologies offered a 200 million
dollar deal for just 1.9 percent of the
company deals of that size are kind of
never easy there's a lot of back and
forth this deal was about the vision
that was shared how big this company can
get
everything else was sort of secondary
Milner's investment allowed Facebook to
continue to expand and it kept the
development of the company firmly in the
hands of its founder Zuckerberg knew
that pushing Facebook advertising even
further was the key to continued growth
for years Zuckerberg believed that
Facebook was in a unique position
hey even with the most advanced
advertising systems that exist they only
have estimates of what someone's gender
might be or what someone's age might be
or what they might be interested in but
on Facebook we know exactly what gender
someone is and exactly how old they are
and exactly what they're interested in
Jeremy Smith is Chief strategy officer
for second Market a company that broker
shares and privately held companies
which cannot yet be traded on the public
market
what makes Facebook so desirable from
the perspective of advertisers is that
they are able to accumulate information
on their users like nobody else the
funny thing is that business normally
view it as data it's themselves it's
their information it's their lives that
they're putting on there but as far as
advertisers are concerned it is the the
Holy Grail of data
pushing the boundaries of that Holy
Grail of data was about to get
Zuckerberg in trouble again in December
2009 he revamped the privacy settings
for Facebook's then 350 million users
unless users individually restored their
settings previously private information
was now available to everyone on the
internet many people just sort of took
that default and somewhat inadvertently
allowed a lot of their information to
become public and and many privacy
Advocates believed that they didn't
explain that or disclose it sufficiently
a firestorm of complaints from users and
consumer groups forced Zuckerberg to
backtrack again sparking concerns in
Congress we are here today to urge
Facebook's Creator and CEO Mark
Zuckerberg to revisit this new policy as
soon as possible we believe Facebook
should reverse its policy to begin
exploring guidelines so users know
upfront what's happening
adding fuel to the fire was the
surfacing of still more instant messages
Business Insider published messages they
said showed a friend asking then college
aged Zuckerberg why people share their
emails with him
Zuckerberg's response was Kurt and
profane you know I I mean I asked him
Point Blank about it and he was very
embarrassed by them by the fact that he
had sent these IMS less than one month
later he was put on the hot seat in a
memorably awkward interview at the all
things digital conference do you feel
like you're violating people's privacy
you know there were real learning points
and turning points along the way in
terms of
um in terms of building things
if I knew what I knew now then then I
hope I wouldn't have made those mistakes
but I can't go back and change the past
I can only do what we think is the right
thing going forward foreign you know
anybody who's ever uh kind of doubted
what Facebook is about or want to
question his Integrity I mean they can
can they can they can keep pointing back
to that right to that instance of like I
can't trust that guy that is that is
going to be our check on him for as long
as he remains CEO you know and in charge
of that company it's gonna be like okay
you're not that guy well prove to us
that you're not that guy
Chris hoofnoggle the director of privacy
programs at the University of California
Berkeley believes Mark Zuckerberg
purposefully pushes the envelope on
privacy in most situations where a
company does something that's unpopular
they have blow back they lose the
ability to do something but in
Facebook's case we have something called
I call blow forward where
um they take two steps forward there's
some type of public reaction and they
just take a little step back and so over
time they've been able to open up
profiles more and more
[Music]
Mark does not think you should be a
different person at work than you are at
the bowling alley
in bed at school
you know he basically thinks you should
be consistent across all these
environments and that's a very radical
view for many older people by the time
Mark Zuckerberg turned 25 in 2009 he had
accumulated so much notoriety wealth and
power that author Ben mesric had written
a book about him and the founding of
Facebook
this story started for me at an email I
received just out of the blue to my
website and Eduardo Severin was angry he
wanted to tell his story he had
co-founded Facebook with Mark Zuckerberg
and then he said had been kicked out of
the company and he felt betrayed and he
wanted to talk Sovereign talked to
mesric for six months about a lawsuit he
filed against his former Harvard
classmate for diluting sovereign's share
of the company according to mesric
Facebook found out Eduardo was talking
to him and they essentially settled with
Eduardo nobody knows for sure what
happened but what I've heard is he got
five percent of Facebook and he had to
sign an agreement that said he would
never speak to Ben mesric again but
mesric already had enough material for
his book my proposal had leaked out on
the web Aaron Sorkin saw it
um Scott Rudin saw it so Sorkin
immediately signed on to write the
screenplay and everything happened very
quickly from there the pre-release
publicity surrounding the movie also
seemed to force Zuckerberg to go on a PR
offensive
the previously pressed shy Zuckerberg
was suddenly everywhere if you build
something great that's what people care
about when people don't care about what
someone says about you in a movie he
gave Oprah a tour of his house in 2010
and announced on her show a 100 million
dollar donation to public schools in
Newark New Jersey 100 million dollars
[Applause]
social network opened in wide release on
October 1st 2010. people want to go on
the internet and check out their friends
so why not build a website that offers
that friends pictures profiles I'm
talking about taking the entire social
experience of college and putting it
online Zuckerberg complained about his
on-screen portrait as a ruthless
socially challenged power geek with no
friends he said there were factual
errors in the script
frame it as if the whole reason for
making Facebook and building something
was because I wanted to get girls or
wanted to get into some kind of social
institution
um and I mean the reality for people who
know me is I've actually been dating the
same girl since before I started
Facebook they just can't wrap their head
around the idea that someone might build
something because they like building
things
[Applause]
though he initially said he wouldn't see
the movie Zuckerberg ended up taking his
entire staff to it he even showed up on
Saturday Night Live you ever end up uh
seeing seeing the film that
social network yeah I I did cool okay
cool thanks uh and uh what did you uh
what do you think it was interesting
extraordinary honor The Social Network
won a Golden Globe award for best
dramatic picture as well as three
Academy Awards
first Tunisia now Egypt
but to an increasing number of people
around the world Facebook wasn't just a
Hollywood movie it was affecting real
life in late 2010 demonstrators started
taking to the streets in Tunisia and
later in Egypt to protest their
repressive governments by this time more
than 70 percent of Facebook's half a
billion plus users lived outside the
United States in Egypt one flash point
for the anger was a case of police
brutality at the center of the protests
was a Google employee who ran a Facebook
page well gonan was the manager in Egypt
of a page that was a memorial to this
guy who had been beaten tortured and
killed by the secret police
and that group became very very large
many many hundreds of thousands of
members during the period leading up to
the revolt against Mubarak
[Music]
Facebook expedited the ability of people
to express their dissatisfaction which
clearly
sped up the process of these revolts the
governments of Tunisia and Egypt fell
protesters expressed their gratitude to
Facebook on the streets one named his
newborn daughter Facebook
and while eel gonim sang the social
networking sites Praises on CNN I want
to meet Mark Zuckerberg one day and
thank you I'm talking on behalf of Egypt
this revolution started on Facebook when
hundreds of thousands of Egyptians
started collaborating content you know
like we would post a video on on
Facebook it would be shared by 50 000
people on their world uh within few
hours
Facebook itself was was very quick to
try to distance themselves from that
political activity I mean obviously they
supported it but they don't really want
to be seen as a tool of change because
obviously Facebook wants to be active in
regimes like China they don't
necessarily want themselves viewed as a
tool of Insurgency
Zuckerberg has taken on a personal goal
that might help him with his mission to
connect the world he says he spends an
hour a day studying Chinese which could
potentially help him gain a billion new
friends it's the fastest growing and the
biggest internet Market in the world
there are hundreds of millions of users
and his mission is incomplete if he's
not in China Mark Zuckerberg's power had
never been greater and once again
speculation grew that he would take his
company public despite enormous pressure
Zuckerberg has been hesitant to pull the
trigger and cash in a hundred years 200
years from now what's going to be more
important the money right or the fact
that he has had this kind of impact or
the fact that he's you know executed and
developed and helped evolve this thing
that is more than just a technology site
and it's more than just a website
and so I think that's why it's never
been about money and it's never been
about status when companies go public
it's a tremendous strain on the
management and in fact on top of all of
that
when you go public you you open yourself
up to even greater government scrutiny
aware of that scrutiny Facebook has
amped up their presence in Washington
with a team that includes several former
White House aides and influential
Capitol Hill insiders political official
after political official will tell you
if you are absent from the debate
you're likely to be the person who kind
of gets cut out
and so presence in that debate
particularly when you know Google and
Yahoo and Microsoft and a number of
other very large players are spending a
lot on lobbying is a mistake
today several Facebook Founders
including Mark's friends and classmates
have left the company to start new
Ventures on their own they've been
dubbed the Facebook Mafia
but much of Silicon Valley Talent is on
their way in
top programmers are leaving companies
like Google to be a part of Zuckerberg's
momentum and Facebook and Google the two
internet behemoths are competing in
other ways Ryan single is a staff writer
for Wired Magazine Facebooking and
Google's relationship is pretty simple
they just don't like each other they're
really I mean they're competing cultures
um you know Facebook was sort of young
Brash wild and Google is like you know
an algorithm company like these are guys
that like any problem there's got to be
a way that they can write a little
algorithm that'll fix it
it's clear that Google missed the rise
of Social and Eric Schmidt has has
admitted to to being a flat-footed uh
around Facebook and around social
they've tried a number of things most
spectacularly the buzz social network
that just hasn't worked then in May of
2011 Facebook was embarrassed when it
was revealed that they had launched a
secret attack on Google Facebook is
doing damage control after Revelations
it hired a PR firm to plant negative
stories about Google Facebook claimed
publicly it was not a smear campaign but
the exchange revealed just how vicious
the competition has become the whole
bursted micellar flap was was really
just an in-your-face expression of the
animosity that has sprung up not only
between these two companies but almost
the personal Shakespearean drama that's
playing out between Google and between
Facebook which frankly has a lot of
former Google execs who would like
nothing more than to supplant their
former company you can't underestimate
how driven Mark Zuckerberg really is he
says his mission is to you know make the
world more open and better places
mission is also to be number one right
he wants to be you know inscribed on
granite above Bill Gates I think he is
well on his way like Gates another
Harvard Dropout Zuckerberg is a fierce
competitor he moved quickly to Vanquish
Rivals Google and Twitter with a
stunning acquisition in April 2012.
Instagram is off the market in an
instant Facebook likes the photo sharing
app so much it's paying one billion
dollars for it and cash and shares ahead
of its IPO but the app is free and has
little known Revenue still Facebook may
need Instagram more than Instagram needs
the money Instagram has become a photo
sharing competitor and a social network
all its own it was considered a radical
and defensive move Facebook cannot take
any chance that any other social network
or oriented toward photos could really
get traction that would you know compare
to theirs and I think so there's a
preemptive quality to this also I think
almost certainly Google was interested
and probably maybe forced Facebook to
act now
one month later Facebook finally went
public in the largest IPO on record for
an internet company making Mark
Zuckerberg a multi-billionaire this is
an awesome moment the CEO and hoodie and
sneakers retained tight control of his
company with 57 percent of shareholder
voting rights Facebook has literally
changed the world we've moved uh from
the country to the Village to the town
to Facebook it's just getting started
too I think it's just going to get
bigger and bigger and bigger
for a site that's able to move from the
dorm room to a site where you know my 80
year old mother and myself and my
chiropractor and my third grade class
all reunites on the site and we all have
something to talk about it's an
achievement
Zuckerberg is just as Visionary as Steve
Jobs
he's going to prove just as influential
as Bill Gates
but he's not dealing with a piece of
Gadget he's not dealing with some
program he's dealing with our lives he's
dealing with our identities so that's
why I think we're all gonna have to kind
of keep him in check in a way
we make decisions at Facebook not
optimizing for you know what is going to
happen in the next year but what's going
to set us up to really be in this world
where every product experience that you
have is Social and that's all powered by
Facebook
it started as a simple question but
became one of silicon Valley's great
success stories it's become in some ways
the pulse of the internet
it's a siren for Freedom we don't like
censorship we don't like being blocked
we think that the open exchange of
information can have a positive Global
impact
a politician's bullhorn and a cyber red
carpet for celebrities reaching out to
their fans to be a successful startup
you need two fundamental things you need
great Founders and you need a great
opportunity blogging Pioneer Evan
Williams with biz Stone and original
inventor Jack Dorsey found that
opportunity in Twitter
which has grown to over 500 million
registered users who send over 55
million tweets per day Twitter presents
a way to broadcast out to the world
it has traveled everywhere but the
flight has not always been smooth
especially for the three-in charge there
was tension at the company from the
beginning about how we turned the
enthusiasm for this very simple product
into revenue and profit
foreign
the product is a short burst of
information
140 characters or less called a tweet
Twitter was started by these three men
Evan Williams biz Stone and Jack Dorsey
by July 2011 a round of funding valued
the company at eight billion dollars
Tim O'Reilly is a publisher and
trendspotter in the world of technology
these guys did something
not because they knew exactly where it
was going to go but because they thought
it was a good thing in and of itself
those are I think often the real game
changers
Twitter's co-founder is blogging
Trailblazer Evan Williams the best and
worst of Evan are two sides of the same
coin Mike Maples is the founder and
managing partner of the Venture Capital
firm Floodgate an early investor in
Twitter I think he's stubborn in the
pursuit of the ideas he cares about but
the thing that I've come to appreciate
over time is he is driven by that belief
the son of a farmer Williams was born in
1972 and raised on the family farm near
Clarks Nebraska Meg herahan has known
Williams since the late 90s he was the
third of four children
and his dad and his father like going
hunting
and Evan's a vegan so I think that's
kind of the sense of how he fit in in
rural Nebraska there's not a lot of soy
drinking vegans on the farms near where
he grew up so William's passion wasn't
farming it was web design and
programming after a year and a half at
the University of Nebraska he dropped
out and drifted from various technology
jobs and startups I started my first
internet company in Nebraska in 1994
which required first explaining what the
internet was
omalic is the founder of Technology blog
gigaome and has been writing about the
web for over a decade you don't go to
school to be an entrepreneur you either
have it or you don't right and F seems
to have it right like you're born with
this the the skill to see opportunities
is innate it's in your DNA and I think
EV belongs to that category of people
who just know what is happening
he took that entrepreneurial Spirit West
to the mecca for technology Geeks
Northern California his first job there
was working for Tim O'Reilly he always
had opinions about how things could be
better he wasn't satisfied with the
status quo
EV was not shy about letting us know
what he thought wasn't working and how
we could do a better job within a year
Williams moved on to writing computer
code as an independent contractor for
companies like Intel and Hewlett-Packard
in San Francisco he teamed up with
software contractor Meg hurray
they became a couple and started a
company together pyra labs
so this is my desk very messy when we
started pirate it was 1999 it was right
in the height of the.com Boom it was a
really exciting time to be in in San
Francisco
power Labs product was a web program
designed to manage projects keep track
of to-do lists and assemble contacts one
small feature was a Williams invented
tool to make it easy to update an online
personal Journal at the time known as a
web log and then as a joke
a friend of ours sort of decided he
wasn't going to call it web log he was
going to call blog Williams saw a new
product Evan's really good with names
and branding and stuff so we should call
it blogger blogger.com became a
sensation
really couldn't believe it you know
every day there would be more traffic on
the website more users signing up and
you would say well this has got to be it
it can't possibly continue at this rate
and the next day there'd be more people
Ryan single is a journalist covering the
tech industry nobody really knew what
blogs were right this was a kind of a
new thing he had this idea he wanted an
easy way to publish online write an
article write something short about
their lives and publish it and this was
this was a new phenomenon blogging was
This brilliant additional layer that
made it possible for somebody to work
just with the content just with the
images they didn't have to do anything
technical so it really made the web the
web for everyone
but the big idea from the small startup
wasn't enough to keep it afloat in fact
it hit an iceberg
the market crash of 2000 was disaster
for many in Silicon Valley people were
panicked.com started to fail we weren't
prepared for how quickly everything
would really kind of shut down
we ran out of money I left because I was
tremendously stressed and freaked out
and like five figures in debt and Evan
kind of closed up shop and took the
servers back to his apartment and
hunkered down to
to sort of ride out the storm the
post.com boom was was ugly in San
Francisco you had this whole group of
people who thought they were getting on
the train to riches who then all of a
sudden had to figure out what exactly
they wanted to do with their life
Williams posted to his blog that he was
now bloggers only employee
it went through some pretty dark times
and a lot of entrepreneurs would have
quit but EV stuck with it when you're a
great entrepreneur you have to you have
to be willing to try a few things and so
if you don't love it when you encounter
Fierce resistance or stupidity or the
inertia that the world throws in front
of you you're going to give up you won't
persevere but if you truly love an idea
you'll be so convinced that you're right
and that the rest of the world is wrong
and just watch me that you'll just keep
plugging away at it and that'll be what
sustains you
Evan Williams was running blogger.com by
himself the company was struggling
barely surviving the.com bust he had
nothing but a great idea when he got a
call from an industry giant he called
his former partner Meg herahan with the
news he said are you sitting down
yeah he said I said really are you
sitting down
I said Choir by Google
the amount of the sale was never
disclosed it's like playing in a double
a league and then all of a sudden you
get a call from the Yankees and they're
like you know I want you to come play in
the playoffs
Google was huge and they were cool and
they were going places that's gonna be
pretty amazing right I've hit the big
time
Google was going places and Williams was
going with them he went to work
developing blogger.com for the exploding
search giant during this time his future
business partner biz Stone was 3 000
miles away on the East Coast working as
a creative director at a competing
blogging website called zanga.com
David Kirkpatrick is an author and
commentator on technology and social
media bizstone is an interesting guy for
Silicon Valley because he's a little bit
more of a insouciant Rebel type
personality I think he's uh he's very
funny and acerbic and prone to kind of
gags Stone jumped on the blogging
bandwagon but grew frustrated with the
direction of zanga he moved to Los
Angeles in 2001 and wrote two books on
blogging for stone Google also came
calling and hired him to help them
develop their new acquisition
blogger.com here's where Twitter's two
future business partners first met the
1999 Evan and I were basically rival had
rival companies and uh EV sent me a note
says how about you come work here for me
so the first time we actually met was
when he picked me up at the airport to
take me to work but their time at the
company was limited after less than two
years at Google Williams walked away in
October of 2004. he had never really
gone to work for anyone or worked at a
company he's an inventor he's an
entrepreneur he wants to be able to
build the things that occur to him when
they occur to him by the end of 2004
Williams wrote A business plan for a new
internet startup called Odio a
podcasting company that would distribute
and publish audio on the web
he raised five million dollars from some
of the biggest names in Angel money and
Venture Capital including Google backer
Ron Conway Lotus founder Mitch Kapoor
and his old boss O'Reilly media Chief
Tim O'Reilly having had a success with
blogger if I had relatively easy to
raise Angel money and VC money around
the idea that podcasting was going to
become a next generation of blogging
Stone left Google and joined Williams at
Odio but the young company suffered a
devastating blow Odio hit a glass wall
named Apple Mike Maples invested 25 000
in Odio we were going to take podcasting
to the masses well a week after he gets
my check Apple gives podcasting away on
iTunes and when you're giving podcasting
away and all of the playback devices are
iPods it's not clear there is a business
anymore
within six months of starting the
podcasting Company audio Evan Williams
reputation as a Silicon Valley success
story was taking a hit
thanks to Apple's iTunes odio's web
music distribution Venture was dead in
the water and by the end of 2005
everyone in Silicon Valley knew it I
didn't really think much of Odio I just
didn't I thought the idea of a
podcasting company which is quite
marginal
while the company's prospects looked dim
there was help on the horizon
enter Jack Dorsey in 2005 Dorsey was
running his own startup a
self-proclaimed computer geek as a kid
Dorsey was obsessed with maps and he
wallpapered his room with them you know
maps of transit systems street maps of
the City highway maps and then as his
family finally acquired a personal
computer he realized that he could
basically draw his own maps on the PC as
an adult his obsession evolved into
creating software systems for sending or
dispatching messages instantly or 911
emergency centers and Couriers and taxis
and whatnot the concept that came out of
this was this very simple here's what
I'm doing anyone who's interested can
follow along in real time
for years Dorsey had been looking to
explore the potential of a dispatch
system that could help friends stay
connected after a chance encounter with
Williams he thought he saw his
opportunity at that point I needed to
get a real job and write a resume and
I'm a very low level programmer and I've
always loved that that aspect but I
wanted to do something different and I
had read about EV from a successive
blogger over lunch at this children's
playground Dorsey described the idea he
had been carrying around since he was a
teenager the simplest thing that we can
do is for me to be able to send out a
message from my phone and have other
people to be able to to read it in real
time
he pressed Williams to let him try it
saying let's just do that it's so simple
to program we could do it maybe in two
days
Williams gave him two weeks
Dorsey asked biz Stone to help develop
the graphics and visual elements
two weeks later they had something
we built a system to immediately take a
message so you could have a 20 Nokia
phone send a message that I'm in the
middle of Central Park in New York City
watching the geese pass by in the lake
and it would go out instantly to all
your friends in real time
on March 21 2006 Dorsey sent the first
message the product worked but the
Friendship dispatch system needed a
catchier name
Noah glass a co-founder of Odio scoured
the Oxford English Dictionary and came
across Twitter short bursts of
information or tweets from birds
it was the most perfect thing because
it's exactly what we were doing Williams
bought out of Odio forming a new company
which became Twitter in April of 2007.
the move cost him two million dollars
effin said to me literally we just don't
think we have a business here and rather
than just spend all of your money and
try to come up with something new or
keep the plate spinning I'm just going
to give you your money back and in fact
a lot of the people that I invested in
Odio with took their money back and
chose not to invest in Twitter and
Twitter is the investment by the way
where if you passed on it it mocks you
every day
Evan Williams was chairman of the board
biz Stone was creative director and the
soft-spoken Jack Dorsey was Twitter's
first CEO
have thought about it for a while and
decided Jack would be the logical Choice
as CEO even though he was had no
experience in anything but coding he was
not a leader in you know from his
business experience and so making him
CEO was a little bit of a of a gamble on
Evan Williams part
[Music]
it was this music festival that helped
Twitter really take off in 2007 at the
annual South by Southwest music and
Technology Festival in Austin Texas
Twitter broke out with the public
and the winner is you can check your
cell phones Twitter
yeah I would like to thank everyone and
140 characters with us
[Music]
thank you
we rented two screens and we put them in
the hallways and they would show what
people were saying about South by
Southwest
when we saw Twitter operating in the
wild for the first time at this Festival
we witnessed people moving together as
one and we lifted this idea out of a fun
geeky Festival What If This Were In
other events around the world
Twitter had met its Tipping Point during
the festival usage tripled from 20 000
tweets a day to 60 000 tweets a day
Twitter just showed up in the world at a
time when there was a demographic shift
in how Computing was being used when
computers were no longer productivity
tools but social tools that enabled
expression it quickly became a vehicle
for sharing what am I reading now what
am I thinking now where am I now who am
I seeing now
but Williams and his team weren't
prepared for how many people wanted to
share as Williams later told Charlie
Rose we had a terrible
first year and a half actually where the
site went down a lot and was slow a lot
and it took us a long time to get out
that almost and almost killed us I think
there was internal tension in the
company Dorsey was struggling as CEO he
didn't command respect because it was
very unclear what this product was for
for one thing so this CEO no experience
uh no real Authority because he really
was working in a company still
controlled by Evan
and a product that was crashing
constantly the only good thing was that
Twitter was taking off like hotcakes
the pressure mounted on October 16 2008
Williams blogged that the company needed
a more focused approach from a single
leader original inventor Dorsey stepped
down as CEO and Williams took over
Jack was devastated because Twitter
really represented the exact thing that
Jack had been thinking about in some
ways for his whole life to be pushed out
was just devastating he took months and
months to recover from that Twitter
found itself on everyone's radar and
that included one very interested
potential competitor it was kind of
looking like Facebook was going to be
pushed off to the side
Twitter was an international sensation
in one year alone subscribers to the
social networking and micro blogging
site grew more than a staggering
thirteen hundred percent
all the attention here on Twitter what's
this attention that got the attention of
Facebook's Mark Zuckerberg
the sense I get is that Mark Zuckerberg
probably has a vision for where he wants
to take Facebook and he probably looked
down the road and saw Twitter on that
road to achieving his vision
Zuckerberg tried to acquire Twitter
businessweek reported he had offered 500
million dollars worth of cash and
Facebook stock which CEO Evan Williams
turned down
by 2008 users were posting 300 000
tweets per day
users that included Oprah Winfrey
and it didn't stop there
being on Oprah wasn't as important as
the state department asking Twitter to
not go on its daily maintenance because
the Iranian elections were being
broadcast on Twitter
following allegations of fraud in the
2009 Iranian election protesters took to
the streets
authorities in the country's censored
cell phone messages newspapers and
websites that covered the increasingly
violent protests
eclipsing traditional and mainstream
news Twitter became the outside world's
primary source for information on Iran
censorship we don't like being blocked
we think that the open exchange of
information can have a positive Global
impact we've always been pro-information
sharing democratization of information
and you know more information is better
by the end of 2009 the number of tweets
went up to two and a half million per
day but Stephen Colbert was not
impressed my guest tonight
co-founder of Twitter why 140 characters
was was texting too complex I mean what
the limit on texts are 160 characters we
wanted to reserve a little bit of room
for a username and so we made it 140 and
standardized there and you'd be
surprised at the creativity
oh
everybody was talking about Twitter but
one big question still dogged the
founders how are you gonna make money
you know it's like I don't think I have
Williams and bizstone would walk down
the street without somebody just sort of
whispering how you got to make money can
you give us an outlook for the rest of
the year at Twitter's first developer
conference in April of 2010 the Twitter
Founders finally introduced a plan for
how the company might make money when we
expect the ad program to be the promoted
tweets that we're launching or would
just launch this week to certainly be
the largest part
um in in a few months but it's going to
take a while to ramp up promoted tweets
allow people to in a transparent way put
marketing messages in front of people
who follow Twitter streams and it'll be
interesting to see how it works I think
that the company knows that it's a work
in progress
on October 4th 2010 came the news that
Evan Williams was stepping down as CEO
of the company
Twitter has grown to be huge and yet it
has yet to really prove itself as a
business and I think that Evan Williams
has not really proven himself as the
right CEO to lead Twitter replacing him
as CEO would be former Chief Operating
Officer Dick Costello we're growing at
just a ridiculous rate you know having
been having run a few other companies
and and having spent a couple years at
Google the pace of growth that we see is
just you know I've never seen anything
like it to costolo long time known
quantity in Silicon Valley the
operations guy even though he's chief
executive officer he's really still the
operations guy Evans uh he's an idea guy
but he's not a CEO kind of a guy
Williams said he asked Costello to take
the job so he could be completely
focused on product strategy
but the musical chairs and Twitter's top
management continued in March of 2011.
Williams departure opened the door for
original inventor Jack Dorsey to return
to a major role taking over as executive
chairman Dorsey tweeted he was thrilled
to get back to work at Twitter it's
pretty obvious that Innovation slowed
down over the last couple years and you
know while Twitter did grow dramatically
it grew without changing itself very
much there was a problem with Twitter
from the beginning that while it was a
really cool technology nobody really
knew what it meant as a business that is
a problem that to some degree has dogged
the company to this day but that hasn't
stopped the world's obsession with
Twitter it's a dream come true for
narcissists but it's also a dream come
true for journalists celebrities media
people Brands anybody literally that
wants to reach a large public with a
series of messages Twitter is having an
impact on World History history there
just aren't very many companies that do
that there's no question that Twitter is
becoming part of the fabric of our
society a way that people communicate in
a way that news is disseminated
it's the twittering of birds that
communication that we don't really know
the meaning of
and yet it is profoundly important